[Música]
joe biden presentó oficialmente a eeuu
las principales figuras que eligió para
su gabinete el presidente electo dijo
que estos personajes restaurarán al país
el líder demócrata certificó su victoria
en pensilvania otro de los territorios
disputados por el presidente tono son la
unión europea avanza en asegurar la
inmunización de sus ciudadanos contra el
kobe 19 bruselas anunció un contrato con
la farmacéutica moderna el bloque ya ha
cerrado acuerdos con otras farmacéuticas
con lo que tendría aseguradas 12 mil
millones de dosis
el alto comisionado de la onu para los
derechos humanos condenó la muerte de un
hombre negro en brásil en manos de dos
guardias de seguridad de la cadena de
supermercados carrefour la oficina dijo
que este es un ejemplo claro del racismo
estructural que sufre la población afro
en ese país
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz los estadounidenses
conocieron oficialmente los nombres que
conformarán el gabinete del presidente
electo joe biden
el líder demócrata dijo que estas
figuras restaurarán eeuu a nivel mundial
agregó que espera que sus nominados
reciban una pronta confirmación en el
senado donde nuevamente hay una mayoría
republicana de sirvan y elevadas
certificaron sus triunfos electorales y
se alistan para una transición pacífica
y sin problemas durante el evento de
presentación el presidente electo
insistió en que este gabinete refuerza
su ideal de que el país es más fuerte
cuando trabaja junto con sus aliados
cambiamos la información con nuestro
corresponsal en washington dice
cristóbal vázquez cristóbal buenas
noches como avanzan los nombramientos
para el gabinete de bailén y cuáles han
sido las reacciones políticas y
económicas a estos
avanzando bien presentó hoy seis de sus
oficiales más importantes lo hizo desde
delaware en wilmington y dijo que estos
seis oficiales están listos para
enfrentar al mundo y no retirarse de él
de estos seis que presentó hoy dos no
tendrán que ser aprobados por el senado
el resto si de hecho le cuento que
bailén tendrá en los próximos meses que
escoger cuatro mil funcionarios que él
decidirá desde su oficina de los cuales
mil doscientos tendrá que ser aprobado
por el senado que sería de mayoría
republicana
hay que mencionar que pues está
pendiente la nueva el nombramiento de
yale lleven al departamento del tesoro
estos nombramientos y el de janet lleva
han hecho que los mercados reaccionen de
forma muy positiva el índice industrial
dow jones de hecho subió por encima de
los 30 mil puntos y el s&p 500 y el
nasdaq los otros índices de wall street
también cerraron con 1.5 al alza
punto 3 respectivamente se conocen
también resultados y reacciones
políticas muchos republicanos están pues
ya empezando a reaccionar y a reconocer
la victoria de joe biden cuando esta
tendencia de apoyo pues sigue creciendo
tanto obviamente en los mercados
financieros como a nivel político
cristóbal pensilvania ha sido el más
reciente estado en certificar los
resultados que otros estados tienen que
dar este paso y que sigue una vez que lo
hagan
sí y pensilvania confirma esto certifica
estos resultados ya pensilvania es el
estado donde nace yo bailé certifican
también los estados de minesota y de
nevada a favor de yo bailé y carolina
del norte certifica los resultados a
favor de donald trump en total hay 15
estados que ya han certificado
resultados electorales faltan 35 más
estados por certificar los resultados
tendrán hasta el 8 de diciembre para
certificar y para pues llegar a algún
tipo de acuerdo legal teniendo en cuenta
las demandas que la campaña de donald
trump ha tratado de imponer en estas
elecciones hasta el 8 de diciembre
tienen los dos partidos para llegar a un
acuerdo porque el 14 de diciembre pues
ya es cuando los delegados electorales
depositan su voto y ahí ya se sabe
oficialmente quién es el presidente que
obviamente pues ya los estadounidenses
no votaron
el presidente elector yo white en eso
gracias por ese completo informe desde
washington y cambiamos del tema porque
se acerca la época navideña y europa
sigue con restricciones por
de coronavirus el presidente de francia
anunció que el país hará una reapertura
gradual a pesar de haber superado las
50.000 muertes por kobe 19 en italia el
plan sanitario para la navidad aún se
discute en el gobierno mientras que en
españa se anunció un plan de vacunación
prioritario
una reapertura lenta y progresiva a
partir de ahora y hasta el 20 de enero
francia empezará a retomar varias
actividades con el fin de concluir el
segundo confinamiento obligatorio en el
país a raíz del coi 19 el presidente
francés detalló su plan de reapertura
asegurando que lo peor de la segunda ola
de la pandemia había terminado
doble de plasma en primer lugar se
permitirá salir de la casa para pasear y
hacer ejercicio al aire libre en un
radio de 20 kilómetros y durante tres
horas se permitirá nuevamente las
actividades escolares extracurriculares
al aire libre se permitirá la
reanudación de los servicios religiosos
con un límite estricto de 30 personas
límites del contexto macro dijo además
que las vacunaciones contra el virus
empezarán a principios de 2021 con
prioridad a los más frágiles en cuanto a
italia el país registró este martes 800
53 muertes porque hoy 19 lo que
representa la cifra más alta desde
finales de marzo el gobierno aún decide
qué medidas adoptar para el periodo
navideño aunque los expertos aseguran
que no hay que bajar la guardia el plan
de españa para navidad se centra en las
noches del 24 y 31 de diciembre cuando
solo se podrán reunir un máximo de seis
personas en cuanto al plan de vacunación
contra el coi 19 el ministro de salud
dijo que empezará a partir de enero les
anunció que los residentes y el personal
sanitario y sociosanitario en
residencias de personas mayor de
personas mayores y con discapacidad
serán los primeros grupos que se
vacunarán francas
frente al kobryn 19 les seguirá el resto
del personal sanitario y grandes
dependientes no institucionalizados
aunque las hospitalizaciones se han
reducido la situación continúa
agravándose en países como rusia austria
y bulgaria que registraron en la última
jornada de récords de muertes la unión
europea de anunció un acuerdo con la
farmacéutica moderna para obtener las
vacunas suficientes para unos 80
millones de personas el bloque ya ha
cerrado acuerdos con astrazéneca y
fisher en alianza con valente que entre
otras con las que tendría aseguradas
unas mil 960 millones de dosis
europa ahora intenta poner en marcha
planes para inmunizar a la población en
riesgo
con un tercer ensayo de la vacuna contra
el hobbit 19 que reporta resultados
prometedores la unión europea se está
preparando para el próximo desafío la
distribución de millones de vacunas en
todo el continente dos de las cuales
podrían recibir la luz verde antes de
fin de año steve outfits guys no si todo
procede sin problemas la agencia europea
de medicamentos nos dice que la
autorización de comercialización
condicional para valiente y moderna
podría ocurrir ya en la segunda mitad de
diciembre de 2020 second love of tease
se marchó en change y la distribución el
almacenamiento y la decisión de quien la
obtiene primero una campaña de
vacunación masiva viene con muchos
desafíos logísticos los preparativos en
alemania ya están en marcha con
prácticas como las que se ven aquí con
los voluntarios de la cruz roja este
centro tiene como objetivo vacunar a
1.500 personas al día en francia se
espera que los médicos de cabecera
jueguen un papel clave
si es posible almacenar la vacuna
durante varios días a temperatura de la
nevera la solución más sencilla sería
que los pacientes se vacunarán con su
médico de cabecera
y si es necesario contaremos con el
apoyo de enfermeras otro gran desafío es
ganarse la confianza de la población a
pesar de que el gobierno francés puso en
marcha una campaña de vacunación masiva
contra la gripe porcina en 2009 menos
del 85 por ciento de la población fue
inmunizada
desafortunadamente mucha gente no quiso
recibir la vacuna lo que sugirió un
fracaso espero que hayamos aprendido de
las lecciones y que nos centremos en una
buena organización porque es un reto
logístico plus eastick se espera que la
campaña de vacunación de la unión
europea dure varios meses
la alta comisionada de la onu para los
derechos humanos michelle bachelet
condenó la muerte de un hombre negro en
brásil en manos de dos guardias de
seguridad de la cadena de supermercados
carrefour la oficina se refirió al
racismo estructural que vive la
población afro en ese país donde más de
la mitad de sus habitantes se
identifican como negros o mestizos e
instó a las autoridades brasileñas a que
aborden esta problemática
la muerte de joao alberto silveira
freitas un afrodescendiente golpeado
hasta la muerte por dos guardias de
seguridad privada en la ciudad brasileña
de porto allegre es un ejemplo triste
pero demasiado común de la violencia que
sufre la población negra en brásil
que no ofrece una cruda ilustración de
la persistente discriminación
estructural y del racismo al que se
enfrenta la población descendiente de
áfrica en el país los funcionarios del
gobierno tienen la responsabilidad
particular de reconocer este problema
existente en el país ya que este es el
primer y esencial paso para resolverlo
hasta aquí en esta emisión de noticias
de france 24 pero los invitamos a que
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]